blue bonds are being sold as a way to
help struggling Nations reduce their
debt it works like refinancing a
mortgage only instead of lowering your
monthly payment and taking the extra
money to redo your kitchen you're
spending it on conservation projects the
test case for the concept is the small
Central American country of Belize which
has become a flash point for discussion
involving hundreds of millions of
dollars including plenty of American
money where's that money going
and can it really help
so we get to the reef you'll see it but
it extends almost the length of the
country about 190
. Australia's Great Barrier Reef gets
all the attention but belizeans call
their Barrier Reef the largest living
reef in the world inhabited by 500
species of fish and 350 species of
sharks you can see the manatees right
there where you see all the trails you
see the light gray oh yeah I do see the
manatees the colors are just incredible
and when the Sun hits it on this angle
wow
Gustavo garone of astrum helicopters
showed us the famous Great Blue Hole a
thousand foot wide and 400 foot deep
sinkhole which began forming during the
Ice Age
[Music]
Belize is a nation overflowing with this
kind of beauty
and also constantly beset by debt a
country that doesn't pay its bills
Belize is also now a test lab for blue
bonds a blue bond is essentially a way
of putting value on in this case our
oceans Julie Robinson is with the nature
conservancy in a case of Belize what
we're able to do was to restructure old
debt that we had or bonds that we had
into new bonds into these blue bonds
that are more sustainable and that also
provide greater benefits back to the
country blue bonds LED Belize shave 45
off their debts by among other things
promising to leave the Barrier Reef
intact and to protect 30 percent of all
ocean water by 2026. and you have a spot
marked it would also potentially allow
projects like this to grow how is the
shark population in Belize now
um so that's when we're in the middle of
really getting a hard and fast answer on
start time was 8 10
Jessica Quinlan is a PhD student and
part of a team that's been monitoring
shark Health here for over 20 years
that includes tagging sharks with radio
and satellite transmitters
as apex predators sharks are critical
for maintaining balance in the ocean
right now it just seems like you don't
have enough information yeah we don't so
preliminarily what we're seeing is that
some species are being caught at
sustainable levels and the fishing
pressure experience isn't something they
can handle but the larger body sharks
that typically take longer to grow
mature and produce Young
some of those species are experiencing a
fishing pressure that we suspect might
not be sustainable the Belizean
government feels that blue bonds won't
just pay for preserving the future but
also serve a more immediate need
Christopher Coy is with belize's
Ministry of Finance some of this money
isn't going necessarily towards Big
Ideas but it's like gas for police to
enforce fishing laws which you can't do
right now correct
yes there's a capacity issue so we need
to build capacity for enforcement for
those those things that you mentioned
but here's where it gets complicated the
deal between Belize and The Nature
Conservancy uses funds insured by a U.S
government agency known as the
development Finance Corporation if
police defaults on these Belize is not
responsible for it
the U.S is why should American taxpayers
accept that risk well I think this is
really the positives in this um the blue
Bond transaction is the the relationship
that it
um that it established with the US's
development Finance Corporation I think
that that in in general
um you can get into the legals of it but
ultimately Belize is responsible if
police couldn't pay its debts before why
do you think it can pay them now even
though it's less
the main difference now and what will
allow for police to pay pay packets that
is that they're much better terms so the
payments are lower they're extended over
a longer period of time so it just puts
Belize in a much better place one
analysis said that of the more than 350
million dollars only 24 million goes to
conservation is that acceptable for you
so I think that there's been some
misinformation it was 23.5 million that
the government placed an endowment
that's going to grow over 20 years and
be above 90 million but in addition to
that the government is making payments
uh annually of roughly 4.2 million per
year over a 20-year period Greenpeace
and dozens of other environmental groups
have criticized blue bonds saying the
deals lack transparency and rack up huge
fees
they also fear outside investors will
merely claim to be helping the
environment just for PR purposes a
practice often called greenwashing
but Belize and The Nature Conservancy
insists blue bonds could be
transformational
not just here
but globally if you want this to spread
this concept around the world it seems
like there's a lot of pressure on Belize
to get it right
sure there is a lot of pressure I
believe all eyes right now are on Belize
it's it's aspirational but it's also
what we're working towards together in
Partnership
so when we come back in 10 years
we won't have to ask the question where
did all the money go when you come back
in 10 years I hope that you will go out
to the Reeves and you will see where the
money is gone is that an open invitation
it is an open invitation absolutely
you've got one massive Environmental
Group saying this is a great idea it can
save the oceans you've got another big
Environmental Group saying it's a
terrible idea and it's not well executed
what are the risks beyond the money I
mean of the enforcement angle of it I I
just don't see how they're able to make
uh it work I mean is it possible in that
aspect we don't know yet I mean it's so
early in I mean this is a 19-year
commitment and we're just at the
beginning of it you know some of the
questions being asked are where is all
this money going is it all lawyer fees
is it legal fees other things like that
is it actually going to be effective
it's a huge red flag with those but
sometimes you have to take that that's
right in order to help